I'm interested that you chose self-help
kind of Trope here with the book the
rules for for Life takes us back to
Samuel's smiles and Victorian sort of
self-help manuals in some some senses in
a a tradition but you you're somebody
doesn't like to be told what to do and
you think you know a lot of modernity is
kind of telling a bit finger wagging or
telling people what to do so why would
you accept your rules would you accept
Jordan Peterson's rules if you weren't
Jordan Peterson oh good good point yeah
well you know you you might also ask in
some sense how I can get away with that
because you know for example last year I
did a series of lectures on the Bible on
on the on Genesis and it's very easy to
make that sort of thing into a finger
wagging morality but I'm not not
including myself in the list of people
who need Improvement I'm not talking
from a pinnacle downwards to my audience
you know I'm I'm stating a a fairly
blunt fact which is that we have plenty
of we have plenty of tragedy and
malevolence to contend within the
confines of our life and we need to
figure out how to deal with that
properly without becoming bitter and
cruel and resentful and these rules are
guidelines to help people avoid those
pitfalls rather than finger wagging
moral injunctions designed to make them
feel guilty and so that's why the
lectures are attractive because that
that kind of top-down morality is
actually absent from them I mean one
view of this large popularity that you
you're enjoying it at the moment the the
the the moment if you like the Jordan
business is that you've captured a kind
of space between what many people think
and what they're being told to think
does that ring a bell with you and do
you think that's a fair description is
that something you're kind of aiming to
do well I think that people are have a
sense that the again that the manner in
which our public discourse is being
conducted has has tremendous danger and
the danger is essentially the elevation
of the collective over the individual
and that that poses a danger both on the
left and on the right and I think that
by appealing to the notion of individual
sovereignty which I would say is the
primary would you say it's the meta
message behind all of the things that
I've been writing about that people find
that to be a great relief even though
what I'm asking them to do is to Bear
more responsibility for what they do
than they might typically be inclined to
and so but it's all it's see look I I'm
facing some of the issues that that
people confront in their lives very
squarely I believe the the fundamental
religious truth of the idea that life is
suffering it's suffering because we're
mortal and fragile and because we're
also subject to malevolence at our own
hands into the at the hands of others
it's a it's a constant existential
problem
and that can make you bitter and can
make you hopeless and nihilistic and
depressed and anxious and pro and likely
to abuse uh substances of various sorts
as as a medication or an escape it can
auger you in in a very large number of
ways and I'm suggesting to people that
there is a way out of that and the way
out is to confront that forthrightly and
to adopt responsibility in your own life
and to try to make the world a better
place and that it's necessary to do that
and that if you don't do that that
things go badly and it's a relief to
people to hear that because they know it
they already know it so get a grip on
yourself well it's it's more find
something in your life that's so
worthwhile doing that the fact that
you're going to suffer is justifiable
but if that something of value worth for
instance for someone to decide that they
are a radical feminist or a radical
trans campaigner that would be something
of Great Value in their lives but these
are not positions that I think you think
have been it's usually have not of Great
Value in their life because what they're
doing is abdicating their personal
responsibility to live by their own
truth let's say to adherence to an
ideology and I'm not a fan of ideologies
I think they're unbelievably dangerous
and I don't really care whether they're
on the left or the right so to be a
feminist or a trans activist or to adopt
that that group fostered view of the
world I think is generally a mistake and
I don't think it does people any good
not usually and it also allows them to
adopt and and this is something else
that's very very gone very wrong with
our political discourse is that it
allows people to adopt an unearned
um an unearned sense of moral
superiority and also of omniscient
knowledge because an ideology offers you
that and there's just nothing in that
that's helpful so what you have
fragments then what you have isn't an
ideology or no it's not an ideology and
you know it isn't a strong collection of
ideas in a sense always an ideal no it's
not it's not and it's a mistake to think
that way because all that means is that
the way that you construe the world is
there's a Battleground between different
ideologies and if an ideology is only
that which serves a power elite let's
say which is part of the post-modern
Neil Marxist construal then all it ever
is is a battle of opinions and there's
nothing underneath that and it's all
power and and that's just not an
appropriate way of looking at the world
first of all there's lots of forces at
play that aren't mere power competence
is one of them assuming that there are
some things that are worthwhile doing
and and then with regards to ideology I
wrote a book about that the first book I
wrote is called maps of meaning and it's
a it's a description of the relationship
between archetypal or mythological
thinking proper religious thinking I
would say and the parasitical structures
that emerge from that which are
basically ideologies and they can be
technically differentiated what do you
make of liberalism I would consider
myself a classic liberal you would
consider yourself yes which is also has
beliefs attached right it comes out of a
a tradition of evolution of beliefs but
there are also there is also a radical
liberalism which it feeds into feminism
which believes that progress is is a
better thing than like a progress of it
the economist is founded on those Basics
and that people can argue about what
they want to to take or leave but do you
include then liberalism as one of the
isms that you would say is in crisis at
the moment or has got itself into it
well well it depends to some degree as
you pointed out on how you Define
liberalism but one of the things that I
like about the classic liberal Take On
The World which which I and to which I
think we owe Britain a great debt of
gratitude for developing perhaps more
particularly than any other country is
that the individuals is to be regarded
as The Sovereign entity in the political
understanding but that's not really a
political claim it's a claim that
underlies politics it's actually a
theological claim it's derived from the
judeo-christian tradition
and because in the judeo-christian
tradition the suffering individual is
The Sovereign entity and we established
a political system based on that
metaphysical Axiom and so I would say
that to the degree that liberalism
um acts out the idea of the sovereignty
of the individual it's not an ism it's
it's not a political stance it's far
deeper than that what it's predicated on
and the uh the the idea of the
sovereignty of the individual is an idea
that emerged with great difficulty over
tens of thousands of years or longer
than that has an immense developmental
history that radically predates let's
say the enlightenment or or any
articulated political beliefs it's far
deeper notion than anything that can be
encapsulated politically but if we look
at the great some of the great classic
liberals of the 19th century and we look
back to Mill for example you have
individual liberty very strongly in
there from Lock onwards a sort of the
sense of sovereignty and no one from the
Monarch down has you know has the right
to unfair sovereignty over another man
or a woman but you also have a strongly
kind of progressive sense that that
develops as liberalism develops and
takes you towards uh women's franchise
towards actually in Mill's case a fairly
out there feminism
Jess Mill was sitting here instead of me
would you be seeing eye to eye on
whether that was a good idea well again
I I think it depends on what what you
mean by feminism I mean the idea that it
would be a good thing for the world to
arrange itself so that the talents of
women were as available to use by the
collective let's say by the group or by
society as the talents of men then
obviously that's all for the good I
don't have any problem with that
whatsoever because talents in short
supply and and it's a foolish society
that wastes it no matter where it
manifests itself racial divisions are
ethnic divisions or any of that equality
of opportunity I can't see how you can
be a sensible person and not do you
think well do women have opportunities
sorry do women have equality of
opportunity than broadly across Western
societies compared to what look compared
to not having equality compared to 100
years ago yes compared to 50 years ago
yes compared to most places in the world
throughout history yes compared to a
hypothetical ideal no
well it depends on how you Define
equality if you define it as equality of
outcome then it's a catastrophic ideal
see this is something too you know one
of the things I've been struggling with
recently is the idea of of of of
boundaries let's say we know absolutely
and and this is relative to relevant to
your questions on progressivism
um we know that the left can go too far
and we know that the right can go too
far I mean I would say that's the abject
lesson of the 20th century both can go
too far and we kind of know when the
right goes too far we probably think the
right goes too far if you had to boil it
down to one thing when people start
making claims of racial or ethnic
superiority that seems to be the marker
but we don't know when the left goes too
far and the left to be frank about it
isn't very careful about differentiating
itself into those who are pursuing a
reasonable Progressive agenda and those
who have seriously gone too far and I
would say that when people push any
quality of outcome agenda they've gone
too far even though it's not as
blatantly horrifying let's say as claims
of ethnic or racial superiority the
consequences of playing that idea out in
the world are seriously not good but
surely they are you know they're two
kind of door stops it's the far ends of
the arguments I mean very few people I
think on the left and there would be
some who would advocate for absolute
equality of outcome and everything it
would take to achieve it's not so clear
to me you know there may be lots of
things that are wrong both on the left
and on the right that don't involve the
right being overtly racist and the left
wanting absolute equality of outcome
it's a space surely in the middle that
matters and that's why I suppose people
feel that sometimes your argument is
almost sort of it's driving towards
picking the fight rather than liberalism
would I suppose
encourage you to take the best and we
can have the argument about what's the
best and what's the worst of everything
that's in between no I strongly I think
that the the left poses a far greater
danger than than your analysis suggests
I certainly see this in the universities
um and the the drum is being beat very
very hard perhaps not so much here but
in North America for equality of
opportunity or equality of outcome under
the rubric of equity and Equity is
essentially a doctrine that Fosters the
notion that equality of outcome is not
only desirable but should be pursued as
an uh an object or as an explicit aspect
of public policy the the idea being that
if
the there aren't there isn't equivalent
representation of all possible groups at
all possible levels of all possible
hierarchies that that indicates a
tyrannical Prejudice that needs to be
rooted out and that's having an
absolutely pernicious effect on on
institutions especially educational
institutions in North America that's not
a and it's an increasingly widespread
View and I think it poses far more
danger than is it do you think is it
possible that views become more
attractive when something is
dissatisfied and when aspirations have
not been met which are reasonable
aspirations to have and you can then say
that the answers are wrong or that they
oh sometimes but sometimes say if this
is such a popular view to cite your
example on campuses in North America it
may be that there's something out there
that existing Society has not satisfied
what hasn't satisfied the ever-present
human tendency towards envy and
resentment that's for sure that's all
that's driving it not all but it's a
tremendous amount of what's driving it
and allow an absolute lack of gratitude
for what we've managed to accomplish and
what we have in front of us I mean
unfairness does that figure
well unfairness is a very ill-defined
term I mean it's not so obvious either
it's not so obvious what's fair so for
example you know I got embroiled in a
dispute the last time I was in you in
the UK about the issue of the gender pay
Gap and you know from from a social
science perspective the idea of the
gender pay Gap is it's it's uh it's so
poorly formulated that it's almost
staggering to me that people can even
conceptualize it in this manner it's not
a univariate problem
it's a multivariate problem men and
women don't make sense so we can break
it down and then we can go through no
not only could we we have to and and we
can't assume that just because in all
situations women don't make as much
money as men although there are some
situations in which the reverse is true
by the way that the reason for that is
Prejudice and oppression there's many
reasons for it